wow this is incredible uh first of all
you got I think all of these wonderful
filmmakers I've spent the week with you
guys are so immensely talented I am so
motivated to keep going out there and
keep fighting for to tell stories you
guys are so inspirational and it's been
a blessing to be in your creative
company thank you so much to the Academy
for including me in such a wonderful
group of people I'd also like to thank
so many people starting with my team my
my producers Melissa and muha my editor
Leo my cinematographer andressa my
production designer Stephanie Haas and
most of all I really need to thank
Christina thank you so much for taking a
chance and coming out to LA and and
filming such a wonderful story with us
you were so brave you're so courageous
and it means the world to me that you
were able to do that for us thank you so
much you've grown so much
I'd also like to thank Laura and
Kristina's entire family you guys are
immensely supportive and it is she's so
blessed you guys are so wonderful thank
you so much for letting us borrow her
for a couple days I have so much fun
working with all of you I'd also like to
thank everybody at AFI I know there's a
bunch of people way up there on the back
there you are what's up guys first off
I'd like to thank some of the faculty
Marie Canton Kevin Jones peter markham
all the teachers Andy walk Andy Wagner
rob's para Brian Donnelly all you guys
everybody are so wonderful to my
wonderful wonderful class of 2014 each
and every one of you pushed and inspired
me and the other guys down here
everybody in our entire class to be the
best that we can be so thank you so much
and finally I'd like to thank my family
to my mom my dad my brothers Joey Paul
Sam and check you guys are my everything
you are my support system when I need it
you are my inspiration for every
creative decision I make you are my
guiding lights everything I do and the
person who I've become is all because of
you thank you thank you so much